welcome to this video coverage for round
six of the round six is rather Game six
of the World Championship match between
defending champion magnus carlsen vishy
anand from india round six is a cousin
white game and we haven't even score in
the match so cards will definitely try
to press with white let's see what
happened today before again yeah it
seems that Carlton has decided to go E 4
in this match the third white game
already where you fall was tried we had
one win against the Berlin and then
Island switch to the Sicilian and we see
exactly the same again to be 6 yeah in
game um form island now had played to
move g3 one of them rather typical for
him non theoretical lines that white has
some as its disposal it's not a bad line
I have played this myself occasionally
as a non-default player in yeah and once
in a while playing for and then I play
sidelines those kind of lines that have
some some poison but they're not totally
the main lines but ok he didn't really
get anything in Game four so in this
game it was time to play something
serious so we have D for the open
society okay and holidays playing a six
interesting that was not a line that
could be expected if you look at
unanswered Korea yes plate 96 the
terminal the 1996 he has played this
really often find a ton of games but in
this match it seems he has to oh yes so
prepared to play a six the con variation
yeah what is the big difference between
those lines there are a number of
differences but one important thing is
that a six year
can't variation played in the game this
allows white to place you form the
maracas see bind set up with c4 and e4
pawns and 96 on the other hand the
terminal is basically preventing that
and the reason is that this variation
here is very satisfactory for black the
difference to the game and we see
something similar in the game is that
black he has played the move knight c6
instead of a 6 which is just much more
useful to put pressure on the center
it's easier to understand maybe if you
see the game this position here is
already very year okay for black in the
game after a six cards nethack played
Seafort and move that only recently has
really come to them to the forefront of
theory to be honest I always thought
that this this is something that why
should investigate but it only recently
has picked up due to one specific idea
that to be honest I also didn't know but
I always sort of had the feeling that c4
is a serious move yeah Knight f6 93 and
Bishop before played by or not if black
is not playing Bishop before the
immediate pin he might play Queen c7
that's the main alternative after that
why it plays a 3 this is strong it
prevents Bishop before and white will
set up a typical kind of formation but
should be three but should be two
castles f3 this kind of maroc see bind
rock-solid in the center and black world
set up hair chalk against that so what
we probably will get something like this
I can this can be played in a ton of
move orders like this b6 something
something along along those lines and
white is going to play before that's an
important point by a three is quite
useful very often what will play before
later anyway yeah and this position type
is some nowadays considered to be a
little bit bad
for white due to the space but ok it's
the head shock and black has always had
some some counter play available it's
very much a playable line but not
something that that honored really am
plays that often the Hedgehog formation
so it's no surprise that he played
differently we go back after ç for 9 f
693 we went with Bishop before this pin
yeah this is a different situation now
then with the knight on c6 of course
black is attacking this but white has
additional options one option compared
to them the position with the night be
126 is the movie 5 not played by cars
and after that there are funny lines
with Queen 85 really really sharp stuff
but okay this is not so important for
the game because cards now played a very
interesting move it's a move that looks
a little bit clumsy but is in fact quite
strongly played Creed III yeah in fact
really a strange move um but it is quite
good why why is this yeah well white
whites queen is doing something very
important it keeps the pawn protected
and it has some very very nasty ideas if
black plays the totally normal looking
move Quincy seven then white can
actually play a three Bishop takes and
Queen takes that's really interesting
why is this possible yeah Knight takes
e4 unfortunately it's answered by night
b5 and why this already reading here
it's really that bad something like pawn
takes Queen takes rook f8 bishop age 6
is going to win the rook well let's say
the exchange white is a piece down so
this is a line that really wins for
light means that Queen c7 is not really
a great idea for black so what should he
play hmm
it's difficult actually if black
immediately takes then white takes with
this and he has this additional idea
that's also not very very good um yeah
when I was looking at at this after the
game I noticed that an interesting way
to play is maybe the moves d 6 which is
a little bit more let's say this is a
more complicated way to play compared to
what are not played Allen's approach was
very straightforward but i'm not sure
that i like it relief to be honest he
played the move knight c6 directly
developing the night and this in fact
gives wide an opportunity that was
gladly taken now by the world champion
Cardinal took on c6 d takes Gabby take C
is really not leading anywhere a three
now it's a really big problem because
black here can cannot even take because
of collegiate seven with an excellent
position for watch yeah so you have you
basically have to take with the deep on
and then of course Carlin just traded
Queens and played e5 yeah it seems that
all this was prepared by Arnold he was
playing this really quickly and also the
next couple of moves they were put on
the board rather yeah it's a quick speed
um yeah he has an interesting moment
after you find what should like do we
play tonight 27 which is technically a
novelty but it is a very natural move in
fact it it is clearly the case that the
move Knight e 4 i believe is not that
great it's a possible move but not that
great white will play a three-year let's
important not a lame moves like Bishop
e2 a three is better Bishop takes pawn
takes yeah and now we have a situation
where we have from a quite similar
situation to the game actually the
difference is that the night now is only
for where it is much less stable
and in fact there are very gap I mean
there are little little little space for
the night to go to yeah okay
theoretically speaking c3 is hanging but
this is really not a pond you you can
take the night is close to being trapped
or being trapped really quickly um I
think this is really not so good if you
compare it to the game in the game we
had a similar situation after night d7
playbar not Bishop f4 this is really the
only move f4 it's not a good idea
because you kill your own bishop yeah it
looks at your pawn now bishop is for as
much better using the pieces not this
move we should have form and now are not
took on c3 so we have a very much
comparable position to what we seen
before only now the night is on d7 and
it's much much safer on d 7 so this is
certainly better in comparison however
what about this position black now
played king to c 7h for this is one of
those moves that are pretty clear to a
strong player but maybe not so much to a
less experienced player YH for ya h4 is
the strongest move em because you need
and want you look developed quickly you
get your look to h3 and then possibly
over here well h 30 h4 in fact after the
pawn is pushed to age 5 so you develop
your rook right on the initial square
and what's very important this upon here
on edge form it's gaining lots of space
on the kingside what white wants to do
is he wants to pressurize blacks Kings
side with his pieces and this is done
very nicely by carlson under now played
b6 yeah the alternative here was aged
five stopping the rook but this has one
very important drawback it makes this
bishop
yeah it gives this Bishop really an
excellent position on f4 I cannot ever
be attacked by g5 or whatever and white
really has a simple plan yeah going to
attack the the the the King side here
also Bishop d3 coming long castles
coming so there's lots of pressure here
and it will be difficult for black to to
defend it was really a matter of yeah
choosing between two to e volts am in
the game when Alan did he didn't play
this but he played b six instead b6 and
after that age five was played yeah now
again typical situation black absolutely
cannot allow h6 which would force g6 and
then he's totally dead on the dark
squares young so he does not want to
have this f7 e6 g6 formation age six is
basically what you what you must do here
um yeah and now after age six white
castle blown it to be honest this
position is so it's a very logical
consequence of the opening choice
bye-bye honored I think when he played
the Khan variation the variation was c4
and and this is Queen d3 could have been
easily anticipated is one of the one of
the fashionable lines there and it seems
that Arnold and his team really went for
this position quite willingly and
tourists I'd like to question this this
decision and you to do two reasons first
of all I think that this is simply not
really good isn't white just better here
I mean look at this the next moves are
very logical and very hard to improve
upon Bishop d7 rook to e3 c5 rg3 and
just look at this this is why it just
better here um okay he has this double
porn but it's nothing that that black
can attack it's not like an obvious
weakness or anything
on the other hand white has an excellent
loop here on g3 always putting pressure
on the King side and the g7 porn and
white has additional ways to increase
the pressure you can put the bishop here
which looks all the way to age 7 and
white has those kind of ideas look aged
44 even increasing the piece pressure on
the pond as still as I simply think that
white is better here and the second
thing that is also I think a bit
questionable is to get this position
exactly against Carlton because this is
just what he loves to do this kind of
position where you're just better a
little bit better even not it doesn't
need to be a fantastic advantage but the
kind of thing that you can press forever
with little risk so this is kind of I
think a dream position for for Carlton
um I'm not really sure why they went for
this willingly it would have been
interesting to to know in them in the
press conference but as we will see
later there were other things to talk
about yeah rook a 2g eight that's
logical I need to defend the pawn which
should be 39 of 8 and Bishop to e3 back
yeah this is a um prophylactic move that
is preparing to react to what exactly is
happening now black playing g6 yeah uh
not really cannot stand to to stay there
passively all the time so he decides to
open up on the King side if we imagine
black doing nothing white will probably
really just do this and pick up this pot
so you have to do something g6 Carson
captured night takes 26 Andrew cage 5
this is a strong not difficult to play
and see but still strong covering E 5
from the side if you just take this pawn
it it won't help you because black has
this funny funny counterblow
with night ext3 check being threatened
this saves black so raw edge five is
much stronger Bishop to c6 yeah this is
a kind of a signal wait strategy but
black really cannot do much more yeah
and here i think we come to a situation
where it's not totally clear cut how
wide is going to increase his advantage
it looks like this porn iran age six is
a goner but there's always a five under
pressure as well and you cannot really
easily plane it two f-4s white covering
e5 because this will also pawn on f4 and
also block your own bishop so it is a
not so easy to see a way forward it is
absolutely clear then why it is better
and maybe even yeah substantially better
but it's not easy to really do something
that that amounts to something decisive
very difficult cousin decided to shuffle
a bit played Bishop see to King b7 root
G for a file Bishop d1 yeah bishop d 1
this is covering this rook so this is
sometimes helpful in capturing this pawn
but black can't really just just shuffle
himself it's never really an idea to
take the pawn bishop c2 we are now wider
threatening to take on g6 twice look
back yeah and now we come to the
absolutely a key position of this game
and the decisive really the decisive
position in a way um yeah as mentioned
why definitely is better but how exactly
are you going to make any progress cards
now played the move King to d2 this is a
move that has some logic of course what
white wants to do he wants to get the
king over so that maybe the king is how
with the defense of those pawns so then
maybe like King King 2 e 2 F 3 King f2
and then maybe you can take on edge 6
after you are totally saved with the
counter plane however this move Kingda
to it has a very substantial problem if
you want to treat this position as a
small technical exercise have a look at
this for black black to play in fact it
is I think not so difficult to spot if
you know that there is something as I
now told one now that was a loud sound
and as I as I told you because black now
really can I guess win the game with the
technical stroke 9085 yeah but the funny
thing is that or the sad thing however
you yeah whatever way you may may look
at it is that Anna didn't play it this
was a mutual blunder he didn't take this
chance yeah 95 what's so strong about
the move the big point is that after
Luke g8 blackheads Knight takes e4 check
and after King b3 agana check yeah so a
very funny tactical motif that secures
black the winner of two pawns here black
is two pawns up white will very likely
win one point back the age 61 but still
this is a fantastic position for black
that he will probably win if we look at
something like this like g3 keeping the
g2 porn chick and maybe something like
that which is fantastic for black mhm
was hanging so probably has to save it
like this maybe
and yeah I can do something like that
and maybe we should be for nature it's a
fantastic position you have many ways to
try to convert your pawns at the moment
it's a it's two pawns even but you will
lose one back as mentioned yeah this was
fantastic chance for hunt and it was one
of those cases cards and played King did
to and he immediately recognized that
there was something of and it I was told
that it was visible in his face but
didn't pick it up it sometimes a very
tricky business this kind of poker face
situations when you have made a better
band move you very often see it right
after you put it on the board and it's
it's good to have a poker face but very
tough to do but it seems an odd maybe
didn't really didn't look at cards and
sometimes it's maybe also a matter of
luck a bit if your if your opponent's
face is clearly giving away that there's
something wrong it's maybe a matter of
luck if you look at it exactly at this
specific moment or not normally you just
look at the board a term it depends on
the player some players are more looking
at their opponents more and some people
are doing this rather rather rarely I
belong to this category i really only
look at the border and sometimes I've
played a game against someone and and
afterwards really quickly forgot how it
looked like because I was just looking
at the ball all the time yeah Kingda to
a big blunder but this she didn't use it
he played after about a minute he played
a for a for ya it is not a bad idea in
itself he wants to go a three and maybe
Bishop a four after preparation but of
course night XD five was a huge huge
opportunity if by the way if Carson is
avoiding kinky too and play something
else let's say rook g3 some some
conservative move then as mentioned
white is better and maybe even
somewhat clearly better but how to
exactly win is another matter it would
have been a huge huge task elephant but
of course he this is a position that he
is playing very well normally and well
Kingda to was really a rare exception of
a blunder in a good position by cars oka
for was played and now Magnus quickly
played kingi to yeah getting the King
out of this out of this business yeah
and by now aland it seems had to
recognize that he had a huge chance yeah
and I think it really effected his play
white is definitely much better
especially now as he has managed this
transfer to e2 without really being
allowed this transfer and was
technically it was a technical mind that
he stepped on with King d2 but well it
wasn't exploited and now wyd really has
gained the idea is really this f3 king
of to possibly yeah a three f three yeah
and with this although some moves that
secure the position it gets more and
more likely that this porn on age six
will drop unemployed rook the eighth
king to e 17 bishop see one attacking
the a three-point okay age and back to e
to those kind of maneuvers they they
don't do very much but they gained a
little bit of time and it's not a bad
thing to sometimes just repeat the
position it's Noah no problem at all
okay are now played Bishop to a to a for
ya that sets probably probably not
helping very much but it's it's
difficult to give him any any great
advice this check Bishop c6 and now
white can take on g6 and this now is one
de-spawn and all this is hanging yeah
this wasn't really helping the special
before but what exactly are you playing
instead as mentioned it's very difficult
to give him any advice as now aged six
is really am a tremendous weakness this
King transfer to 2 e 2 has helped write
a lot yeah he probably could have
defended better maybe maybe 97 here yes
something like that I think this was
mentioned in the press conference
putting trying to put the night here but
I mean while definitely this is tougher
then then the move that you played for
the bishop a4 move it is not something
that it's very likely enough to hold the
game they look at something like rook g7
for example I mean yeah Brooke g7 what
exactly is blacks move now why doesn't
totally control that he would win
material yeah okay in the game this
Bishop a form wasn't helping let's go
back Bishop a form check Bishop back and
now why took that twice yeah and here
white is already winning e6 Hanks and at
age six is lost what he was trying I
mean Anand it's a some counter player
with with with Bishop d1 a rookie one
but it's really nothing serious rookie
one was played and what can really just
take here there is nothing nothing
dangerous happening rue k 1 king III
here and now this rookie 7 check and
after that move from anand resigned yeah
there's really no way to save himself he
goes here this engage 6k to Bishop c5
and everything is falling apart yeah so
it wind for Carlton and what I mean
basically it's it's not mattering how
the result of the overall matches this
will be the key game probably because it
was a winning from cars out of a
position where at one point we jump back
with night XD v 5m where on earth could
have gotten probably a winning advantage
and the difference is so substantial
instead of a Carlton lead with one point
Arnaud would have led the match and yeah
the difference is soap so big I'm very
very huge blow to announce chances in
this match he's down one point now and
well out of out of this position to be
honest I watched the press conference at
least parts of it and I was really am
surprised and yeah it's really admire
about how composed honored was after
this game I mean the kind of the kind of
game where you really don't want to talk
to anybody and he managed to to do a
pretty decent press conference some of
those some some of those questions are
yeah a little bit borderline mean they
were they were pretty okay this time but
there were cases where we are not really
last time especially in chennai when he
had played a terrible end game and lost
a game where really was totally angry
with himself and then people repeatedly
asked in the press conference how do you
feel how do you feel yeah and is this is
kind of the most stupid stupid question
ever because about how do you feel
terrible of course yeah i mean i don't
really know some some of those questions
are really weird because i mean even in
in other sports those questions are not
asked if you let's say you lose a
terrible game of chess and you get asked
how do you feel I mean this is like if
you you remember the the semi-final off
of soccer this year where brazil lost 71
to germany in the semi-final and if you
lose 71 in the semi-final in your own
country and then reporter will asked one
of the brazil players how do you feel I
mean the only answer is just punch this
guy in the face so you don't ask this
kind of question you really do know that
the guy is feeling terrible you don't
have to rub it in in a way yeah so a
very important result in this game and
pretty pretty weird occurrence but
happens on the highest level one
explanation by the way is that the
situation here really was not very
tactical Arnold was not searching for
technical tricks in a way but it's still
surprising because the move Knight e5
was in the position all the time and
somehow it didn't occur to him it's it's
really really am surprising that he
didn't that he didn't see it ok I hope
you enjoyed the coverage of this game
I'll be back with I think Game seven it
is and this will be played on Monday the
surest day on Sunday thanks for watching
till then bye